I think one of the most important
findings in my book and my research is
that innovator is fundamentally
misunderstand human capital as an asset,
human capital,
as a resource.
The majority of organizations that want
to innovate,
say we need to get innovators,
we need to improve the capabilities and
competencies of our employees.
We need to hire people who are willing
to take a chance,
et cetera.
It's such and be innovative and the
whole notion of,
you know,
our competitive advantage in this post
industrial era is that we have better
human capital than our competitors.
You know,
Google has better people than IBM has
better people than apple has better
people than Amazon and blah,
blah,
blah.
I submit that's the exact wrong way to
look at it.
Not that it's wrong in the sense of
false but wrong in the way of being
incomplete.
What about your customers?
Human capital.
What about your clients?
Human capital,
the Good Duncan experiment,
the thought experiment I want people to
get very,
very serious consideration to is what if
we stopped thinking of innovation as
something that's new and valuable that
we market and sell,
and what if we start thinking about
innovation as an investment in the human
capital capabilities and competencies of
our customers?
Yes,
Henry Ford transformed the factory
production system with mass production
of the automobile,
the model t,
the model a,
etc. And everybody celebrates that as a
milestone in business history,
I submit that economic historians,
business historians,
marketers miss the essential point.
Henry ford didn't just enAble the mass
production of automobiles.
He facilitated the mass creation of the
human capital of driving.
everybody drives.
It's an asset.
It transforms markets.
It transforms individual and
organizational capabilities.
Why do we not spend as much time
focusing on the human capital and adding
value to the human capital of our
customers and our clients as opposed to
our employees.
I think that's the essential innovation
takeaway.
How do our innovations transform the
human capital of our customers,
not just the human capital of the people
who work for us and with us.
The reason why I came up with a design
horistic making customers better makes
better customers is because I wanted to
help innovative organizations filter and
prioritize their innovation investments.
it's not enough to make your customer
better if you don't reap the benefits of
that investment.
Conversely,
if we're just making it better customer,
that's exploitation,
so what you're trying to do is align an
innovation investment that makes your
customer measurably better in some way
that matters to that customer in some
ways that matters for that client,
but at the same time,
at the same time,
you're making that customer more
valuable to themselves.
you're making them more valuable to you
by making them a better customer.
You're making them a better customer for
you.
Making customers better makes better
customers.